so uh the title of the talk is high
performance Computing in the cloud um
and I just want to do a bit of context
setting up front um I'll start with on
the right hand side who this tutorial is
not for and I'm not going to be talking
about optimizing an HPC cluster if
you're really deep in this space and
you've been doing it for a long time
you're thinking about optimizing like
Hardware in the operating system kernels
or you want to build an HBC
infrastructure to compete with open AI
or something we're not really going to
be talking about that kind of scale
we're going to be talking more about how
do you make the concepts from HPC more
accessible to data scientists um the
company that I work for we often talk
about kind of reasonable scale machine
learning your AI for for companies that
aren't necessarily Google Microsoft the
Fang
companies um if you if you want to maybe
make it more accessible to data
scientists with good enough performance
in in a way that's easy for software
Engineers to maintain um so that that's
really going to be the focus of the talk
rather than kind of building from the
ground up like how do you do custom
optimizations to Cuda kernels or
something like this um so if you're
looking for that stuff very interesting
topic but not really what we're going to
be going into
today uh so the agenda is to start off
just by kind of introducing like why
what is the connection between HBC Ai
and now the cloud then we'll go into
like what actually makes ai workflows go
and how do you access these kinds of the
kind of infrastructure that you need to
make that happen in the cloud and then
finally in part three will kind of bring
it back to python land since of course
we have high data and we'll see how can
you do these kind of core Primitives
that you need to run um AI workflows in
in a style that's much like HPC
workflows how can you actually do that
from python code in a way that's natural
for scientists who are more used to
interacting at the Jupiter notebook and
python script level and say logging into
some sophisticated HPC cluster and kind
of understanding how to how to interact
in that kind of system
cool so I'll I'll uh Breeze through the
first section um just to kind of
motivate the topic and then I'll pop
back over to the chat and maybe answer
any questions um as we move through the
different
sections so the first thing I want to
kind of get get on board is that like
people are moving to the cloud um this
isn't really a secret to people in
software engineering um it's been
happening for over a decade um and the
the pandemic really accelerated the
desire for especially businesses to move
workflows to the cloud where they can
have more flexibility around how they
just access the economics of doing
especially computationally intensive
jobs like we're talking about
today
um also another big Trend that's
happening right now is that everyone
knows AI is hot um chaty PT stable
diffusion all these models in the last
couple of years have really like brought
AI into the Forefront of people's minds
even outside of the engineering and soft
software development communities um so
companies are looking to invest and
developers are being tasked with
Building Systems to maybe use these apis
or for businesses that really want to
kind of have their own positioning in
their own defensible mode around AI to
actually start to build some of this
stuff
themselves um so now just going right
into like okay why why does compute play
a role here like what's the connection
between the desire to build our AI
systems and the desire to increase our
capacity to do high performance
Computing so this is coming from a sort
of seminal paper from the 2020 I want to
say maybe 2021 that came out of open AI
called scaling laws for neural language
models basically what they point out in
this paper is that they trained a whole
bunch of different neural networks that
are kind of shaped like these GPT models
architecturally and they demonstrate in
these three simple l curves that there's
kind of three main contributing factors
that are leading to the models
performing better the first one in the
one that they kind of argue is the most
important in this paper is the size of
the model just the number of parameters
that you're storing in the in Ram as you
train the model and then at inference
time of course as you make
predictions um the other is the the size
of the training data set so for language
models this is measured in tokens which
is like little chunks of
words um maybe it's like a little bit
bigger than a word maybe a little bit
smaller depending on how you tokenize
the data um but anyways the number of
these tokens in the training data set
that the model is exposed to is the
second scaling factor that they point
out has a huge effect on the ability for
the model to learn and then finally
there's also a relation between these
two and compute the capacity to actually
like run the operations that learn like
allow the model to learn to update the
weights parameters in the model um as it
sees new data and learns um kind of how
to keep predicting the next token in the
the case of pre-training these large
models so the relationship between the
number of parameters and the size of the
data is essentially what what they're
pointing out in this paper is that as
you continue to increase the number of
model parameters there's a very direct
correlation and something that is like
one of the things AI researchers are the
most confident about right now is that
if you keep raising the number of model
parameters the model is getting
increasingly sample efficient the upshot
of this paper and has been validated in
research sense where if you keep
increasing the model size on average
like of course there's edge cases to
this but on average people are finding
that the models are able to learn and
achieve the same performance on
evaluations seeing fewer samples in the
data um additionally something that came
out of this paper that I'll call back to
in a few slides and maybe it wasn't as
in the Forefront of people's minds at
the time of this paper um is that the
optimal model size is also growing with
compute so there's kind of a complex
relationship happening here because I
just said we get more sample efficient
with more model parameters but then also
we're kind of having this relationship
where maybe the optimal size of the
model parameters just depends on what
you can you can do like what kind of
computers and how many of them you can
access um so the the big claim from this
paper though like putting that compute
Point aside um is that as you increase
your compute essentially what they're
pointing out here is that you should
focus more on making bigger models
instead of growing a bigger data set was
kind of part of what they're claiming
here that the improvements that they
were seeing were growing faster with the
size of the model than the size of the
data
set now a couple years later some
researchers from Deep Mind um the
research lab um that's been very much in
the news this week um and is kind of the
main competitor of open AI um they they
releas released this paper that's known
as chinchilla in some circles um the
title of the paper is actually called
training compute optimal large language
models and essentially what they point
out is they sayy hold on like it isn't
just about increasing the model
parameters that's not like strictly more
important and they run a whole bunch of
benchmarks of their own demonstrating
that actually scaling the the training
data set size the number of tokens in
that data set is as important as
training is scaling the number of model
parameters compute
but if you look at this plot on the left
side the thing to notice is is that
there's a same through line so even
though the kind of like the the punch
line of this paper is countering what
open AI said in their their previous
paper on scaling laws there's the same
through line of there's a clearly
optimal model parameter size um for each
compute capacity so these bull-shaped
curves here are essentially showing that
as the color goes from this light green
to the dark purple we're increasing our
compute meaning we can keep getting
better and better models but there's
kind of a there's this like bull shape
meaning that there's an optimal value
for how big of the model we can make and
it depends very much on how much compute
capacity that we have so we're kind of
in this world now where we know that
More Sample efficient learning requires
more compute but then also if you can't
keep increasing your compute there's
going to be worse performance eventually
and kind of the the challenge here is
that if we look at the the plot that's
on the right hand side now it's showing
that all of the models that are the most
competitive are exponentially growing in
model size so kind of all of this
together means that it's an extremely
important capability for people to have
the ability to kind of uh access serious
compute power if they want to have their
own AI systems that are reasonably
competitive so then the question becomes
how how do you actually increase compute
how do you increase that parameter C in
the the three parameters that we were
just looking at at in that story so
there's there's a couple ways um
vertical scaling is the first one and
then horizontal is the second we'll talk
about so what I'm showing here is that
on the top there's basically you can
kind of get a bigger GPU say you're
using a V100 card from Nvidia you could
upgrade that to an a100 card the more
recent generation it's going to have
more RAM it's going to have more
throughput um kind of all the things
that you need to increase this compute
capacity on the bottom it's arguable
whether this is actually vertical
scaling some might call it horizontal
but what we're basically saying here is
like you could also go from a machine
that has one V100 card to a machine that
has four of them or some number of them
um so this is like maybe if you're an
AWS land you could say I want to go from
a P3 2x large instance to one with 16x
large that has eight gpus on it or
however many so basically the point is
is scaling up on one machine to have
more GPU
cards the other way which which is more
of this HPC style scaling that we're
kind of talking about today and is the
kind of the the real way that you can
extend C just depend like it it becomes
like a less of a how is this technically
possible and it becomes more of just how
much can you invest in continuing to add
more nodes into this cluster is is the
is what the economic problem becomes um
where essentially instead of trying to
pack more gpus onto the same machine we
start thinking about okay we know
there's going to be four gpus or eight
GP Ed for machine how do we now connect
these machines in a chain which is
something we can just kind of keep
repeating that
process um now I want to come back to
the AI piece of this um but before I do
that I'm actually just going to exit the
slides and just double check the chat if
there's any
questions oh thanks Tom yeah exactly um
yeah if if you're interested in this
stuff definitely check out the paper
that Tom linked
um okay so I'll go back here um so now I
want to connect this whole like I talked
about kind of the the scaling way where
you could add more gpus or you could add
many machines with more gpus on each of
them um now I want to connect this to
the neural networks actually like these
what are these models and how does it
how do they relate to what the gpus
are so there's three approaches I'm
going to talk about data parallelism
model parallelism and pipeline
parallelism and the first one is is this
notion of data parallel them so on the
left hand side just kind of consider
that as the scenario that we're in we
have this neural network this model um
where these gray lines connecting the
the nodes in the neural network are the
weight matrices these are the things
that we actually need to store somewhere
inside of a gpu's memory and then then
we need to update them to that's what
learning is in deep learning um then we
have these little green squares the
green squares are representing data sets
so this is the training data that we
push push through the model and then we
use that to learn how to update these
weights the the gray matrices in this
picture um and then the Third Kind of
graphic we have over here is there's got
to be some way to then connect these
these uh purple squares which are still
representing the gpus in our cluster
that we have available to so so each one
of these is kind of like its own
computer its own
process um so this first case we're
talking about a technique called Data
parallelism to train the models and this
is something that people do when the
data set is too big to fit in the ram of
a single GPU so if if we can't fit this
green square on any of the the purple
GPU boxes here we need to split up the
data set and then we can fit the entire
model in this case on the GPU on each
GPU so but then we split the data set so
each GPU is only ever seen kind of A
Shard of the data in this case we have
four shards um but again the entire
model is is sitting on the
GPU um what this looks like in pytorch
code is um I mean this is obviously
pseudo code but essentially like you can
pass the entire model to the GPU device
for that instance um we'll we'll go a
little bit more into this and see
examples later in the
tutorial um but the the point here is
that unlike a technique we're going to
look at next the entire model exists on
the GPU and then we're just passing
parts of the data
what's important to realize about that
um is that the forward path through the
model so the model is making predictions
while it's training the these are kind
of independent of each other each model
has its own copy of the data then after
we push those predictions through we get
some like gradient computation which is
the way that the models learn um not
really going to be a tutorial on this
that's like a very very in-depth
research topic is like how to actually
do that gradient syncing
that's not really what we're talking
about here but this is a very important
research um research path to consider um
so anyways after we do those independent
forward passes there's some way that
these different worker nodes these
different worker gpus now need to
coordinate those gradients and kind of
pass them over the network however you
connect these gpus or CPUs together um
and then we can also like once we get
those gradients we can independently do
back propagation on each machine um so
this is this is one way that you can
kind of think about
how to do um distributed training
machine learning is this data parallel
way now another technique is called
Model parallelism and before with data
parallelism we were saying the data set
was too big to fit in the vram of each
of our processes in this case we're
saying that the model itself is too big
so there's too many parameters in in
these models um like you may have heard
gpt3 in their paper they say they use
175 billion parameters um if you think
of kind of how bit how many um like what
is the floating Point representation of
that say you use float 16 that's going
to be like an way too big to fit in the
GP the GPU Ram of the biggest processors
that Nvidia makes and are reasonably
available I mean they make some now
nowadays that are crazy expensive and
can do these kinds of things um but
anyways for for all intents and purposes
there becomes a point where if you want
to train a model that's that big you
need to actually break the model itself
up into different parts and then send
different parts to each GPU so in this
case we see something like you kind of
our splitting this first layer on um on
the first GPU and then you're putting
the second part the second layer on the
second
GPU and what this looks like in the pych
code is say you kind of have these two
different you kind of like break the
model itself up into two chunks two
different objects and then you can send
each of those different chunks of the
model to different devices using kind of
the very high level apis that P torch
mix available to you but all the modern
deep learning Frameworks will have some
API like this to send different parts of
the model to different different
gpus what's interesting about model
parallelism relative to what we were
looking at with data parallelism is that
the pa the forward pass um for each data
point for each batch of data actually
becomes dependent on other GPU workers
in a way that it wasn't in the pure data
parallel case um similarly then the the
actual ability to do back propagation
becomes dependent because part of the
model that you need to kind of get
information from is on a different GPU
in order to do these
things um I won't spend too much more
time here but the other the other thing
to realize is that you can combine data
parallel with model parallel and that
that's really the stateof the-art for
doing these very high scale very high
throughput um AI training
workflows um the final thing I'll point
out here is that there's something
called pipeline parallelism my graphic
looks like it got cut off here um but
with pipeline parallelism what we're
talking about is is basically making
model parallel more efficient where that
thing that I said where if I want to
push say we say we have this neural
network that has one two three four
layers um like four of these kind of
gray connective layers between the
neurons um and we break each of those
four layers up onto its own
GPU um in order to do the computation
for the second layer on the second GPU
the first layer needs to complete and
then similarly on the way back in order
to do back propagation on the first
layer we need to have the result of the
back propagation on the second layer so
on and so forth so people have very
cleverly realized that okay if you just
kind of wait for one batch of data to do
this um you're going to have a bunch of
time where these expensive GPU workers
are idling and not doing any useful work
so we can break the batches up data up
into smaller chunks and then we can kind
of increase our utilization of these
Resources by kind of threading these
different chunks
cleverly um there's a whole bunch more
techniques that you can kind of layer on
top of this stuff and this again is a
really active area of research to look
into but these are some highlevel
concepts for getting
started cool now coming more to like
getting into like more of the practical
part of this tutorial is the transition
here is essentially like how do you
actually do this stuff in practice and
this is where the thread to coming back
to HPC and more like Traditional High
Performance Computing workloads comes
into play um almost all of these deep
learning Frameworks are either actually
based on MPI or conceptually based on
MPI um which stands for message passing
interface and is a protocol that's
existed since the early 90s um to
essentially run exactly these kinds of
jobs where you want to log into one
computer that computer knows how to talk
to a bunch of other computers in the
cloud or in in an on premise Data
Center and you can just run one command
from that main computer and then all the
other workers just kind of contribute
their resources towards getting the job
done so connecting that idea then to
like what are these what does it look
like to actually run code in these deep
learning Frameworks like we'll see in a
little bit here what that what like a
live demo of what this actually looks
like um the main thing I want to point
out on this slide is that there's a
whole bunch of different ways to run the
same code in deep learning right now so
pytorch is probably the most common way
to write your python code for deep
learning and if you want to run it in
this way on um doing distributed data
parallel or model parallel you can do it
through any any of these Frameworks and
there's plenty more that aren't listed
here torch run is one that's supported
by the pi torch team you can see it's
very simple in your command to just kind
of say how many nodes you want to run on
um MPI can also run the same program and
then there's this new thing from
Microsoft called Deep speed that
essentially Builds on top of torch run
um and has a whole bunch of
optimizations that Microsoft researchers
are using to train their
models um now two more points before uh
we kind of get more into the like Cloud
infrastructure part of this tutorial and
talk um that I want point out are more
just kind of like product considerations
or kind of internal tooling
considerations if your organization is
seriously considering going down this
route um one of the main things that in
my experience and that I've heard
customers from the current company that
I work at and previous companies that
I've worked at talk about is that AI
research gets blocked when researchers
need to do a lot of context switching
between thinking about research code and
kind of being in the mindset that you're
in when you're iteratively developing in
a Jupiter notebook and they need need to
switch from that mindset into figuring
out how does my compute cluster work or
why isn't my job getting submitted
correctly to AWS batch or to kubernetes
Cluster wherever you run the torch run
deep speed MPI commands
on um and then the other main point to
think about um is that we we are working
in teams and these workflows are running
on very expensive hardware and the
infrastructure to actually make this
possible we don't want to be
underutilizing it we don't want one
person to be monopolizing all of the use
of that um and kind of at the same time
like the people who actually have to
manage these compute layers the platform
Engineers the devops engineers these
type of people it's very hard for them
to consider like oh we should just
separate it all so each scientist gets
their own compute cluster or maybe we do
one kubernetes cluster over here and one
slurm cluster over here um this kind
this kind of adds operational expense to
these people's work workflows um to kind
of have to maintain and manage many
different cues of work like that um but
at the same time scientists just kind of
want to submit their job and again they
want to separate their concern of I want
to do the research of making AI better
and kind of iteratively improving our
data sets in our models I want to
separate that from like how does the
model actually run and where does the
data actually come from and connect to
the compute
layer cool so those are just some
considerations um not going to propose
any sweeping solutions to this um but
I'm going to show you a bit of a demo of
how you in this section towards the end
how how you can kind of get started
going down that Direction with um with a
tool called Volcano that helps you do
basically do this kind of stuff on
kubernetes in a way that really is going
about this problem when when researchers
are working in teams how do you kind of
help people share the resources that are
in the compute
cluster I'm going to go ahead and pop
back to the chat quickly see if we have
[Music]
anything yes um you know I'm actually
going to
[Music]
share the slides right now as well so if
you go to this GitHub repository the
slides are in this PDF um and I see that
people are sharing links in the chat the
the links in that PDF are hyperlinks so
they're going to go out to all the
papers that people are linking in the
chat as
well
awesome okay so now what what is this
infrastructure to do these kinds of
things actually look like in the cloud
landscape there's three boxes here um
these are these are kind of noisy like
the way that they're positioned on this
graph but essentially the way that I'm
thinking about it in in this
visualization is that on one axis you
have the operational expense to maintain
these systems um this is kind of
ignoring that there's a huge upfront
cost as well that you should consider um
but this is more like kind of the steady
state consideration on the cost measure
and then on the vertical axis we're
thinking about the effort to get going
like how much engineering skill do you
need how how much are you going to need
to kind of invest in R&D to get this up
and
running um in the bottom right we we
kind of have the the what I would
consider the one that's going to kind of
increase your operational expense the
most um but it's going to be the easiest
to get started and it may even be the
most cost effective if you're if you're
a team that doesn't have a bunch of very
skilled kubernetes Engineers or Cloud
infrastructure Engineers um these are
the options that of the cloud providers
is going to kind of sell you as a
prepackaged service things like sag
maker Azure machine learning Google's
vertex these Solutions are kind are able
to do things like distributed training
and they give you very high level apis
they're not super flexible in terms of
what you can actually do on the compute
cluster itself but that's part of the
value that they're providing and
charging you a premium
for um then in the middle we have this
layer that's more of a platform as a
service model um things like Google
batch AWS batch is is the longest
existing one and um we'll actually see a
demo towards the end of this talk of how
to use AWS batch to do distributed
training um and then on the top layer we
have this more like kind of DIY custom
infrastructure things where you can get
really high levels of control things
that you can run in your own on- premise
data center so you could take like
theoretically you could take the same
exact code run the kubernetes code to do
this distributed training on the cloud
then also run it in your data center
same thing with
term um and I think the idea here of of
this talk really like the punchline of
the third part of this talk is that if
you have a good AI development platform
um whether it's some some rapper that
you build around Google Vertex or sag
maker um or AWS batch or it's kind of a
homegrown kubernetes cluster things like
this a good AI development platform
should ideally be moving you down into
the left on this
graph um this these charts now are kind
of comparing some of these different
solutions on a few of the different
questions you might want to ask it's
definitely not complete um and it's kind
of an ey chart I don't want to like kind
of just read it line by line um so again
I shared the PDF in the chat folks who
want folks who want to kind of look at
this and comments on it would would be
much appreciated um yeah you you can
read through these in your own time um I
think the main thing to think about is
just that there's a lot more questions
than this and these are kind of the
basics of how do you form the cluster
how do you submit a job to it
like what what kinds of uh supply chain
you actually need to have to get the
compute nodes in this cluster up and
running um and then of course probably
the most important one I think for for
the kind of platform engineer types to
think about especially if you're going
to be doing this home grown cluster on
your own is how are the different nodes
going to communicate and how are you
going to install all of the network
interfaces and things that make that
fast because that's where that's the
biggest opportunity to kind of build an
efficient system and it's also the
biggest potential risk to have a very
inefficient system that makes things
like gpus become more of a cost sync
than really driving value for
you um so now I want to consider like
there's a lot of people that are
interested in in kubernetes right now um
especially like the customers of outer
bounds and um the people that we tend to
work with um so I wanted to just kind of
have a brief aside on sort of this
do-it-yourself more custom
infrastructure path and compare two two
leading options right now
um so the the two options are slurm and
kubernetes um slurm is much older and
has been around for a while and has been
focused on HPC since its Beginnings um
essentially it focuses on this notion of
a batch job where you want to submit
some workload to run on multiple
different nodes you want to make sure
that all the nodes that you need to run
the job are all available before you
start running it anywhere for efficient
for efficiency reasons um in this is
referred to as gang scheduling that that
idea that I have four different
computers four different workers and I
don't want to waste the resources of
three of them by scheduling the job
partially if I can't access all four of
them at once because I know that this
job is going to need that much compute
power to run efficiently um slurm also
has a lot of features um around priority
cues so this problem that I was talking
about
around there's 10 researchers all trying
to contribute all trying to submit jobs
to the same compute cluster how do you
fairly share the resources of that
compute cluster so that one person
doesn't just submit all a bunch of jobs
and then block all the other researchers
from getting their work
done um so slurm has been around for a
while as I said and and it's it's very
established for HPC and AI training um
and then there's kubernetes which for
the past decade has kind of been the new
kid on the Block and is more of a
general system um and it has really
really strong momentum in developer
ecosystem so
kubernetes is typically in the machine
learning context more considered as a
solution for serving models and doing
things at inference time because it
focuses on things like autoscaling in
kind of cloud native features of like
packaging up a Docker container um a
tyght computer environment and kind of
being able to scale to many different
nodes dynamically things like this um
but it's historically been less focused
on these kind of big training workloads
where the computers are each Having
Eight gpus on them or something like
this um but more recent there's been a
lot more pickup in the kubernetes
community of people trying to actually
move these batch workloads into a system
like
kubernetes um one of the knocks or one
of the things that people might say
about kubernetes is that it's not really
scalable in the same way that slurm is
um or that it's not built to do batch
jobs um but I think there's been some
recent evidence that kind of dispel that
that where essentially like open ey has
written a Blog saying that that that's
what they're using to change gpt3 clip
and Dolly is that they've made a custom
kubernetes cluster that has 7,500 nodes
so maybe the biggest one in the world um
and then even more recently the uh X
announcements um Elon musk's AI around
grock they also in their announcement
post discussed that they are using um
kubernetes in their training and
inference
stack um another Point here another to
consider this from is that the cloud
itself is becoming competitive as a
global
supercomputer um so historically it's
been like these National Labs and kind
of government facilities that have the
biggest supercomputers in the world
sometimes academic
clusters and it's almost been sort of a
joke in the HPC Community to run CL like
to run the HPC jobs on the cloud just
because it's going to be very
inefficient and very expensive XYZ and
like the benefits of the cloud like the
dynamic kind of economics benefits of
using the cloud don't really apply to
HPC um that last part may still be true
but the fact that the clouds are now
becoming serious supercomputers is is
kind of undeniable um as evidenced by
this recent ranking of the top Global
super computers where Microsoft's Azura
cluster is now ranking up near kind of
these the most optimized clusters in in
the United States and I think this list
is actually even Global as well so very
impressive by the Microsoft
there okay so now I want to get into a
demo um do something live um so what I
wanted to do is make it as easy as
possible to get started with one of
these systems um it's called Volcano for
using pie torch to write the code and
then submit the code on a kubernetes
cluster and then once you've submitted
the code on a kubernetes cluster you can
kind of start to like expand this out
towards adding nodes into your
kubernetes cluster just rewriting the
pytorch code a little bit as a
distributed job so on and so forth um so
if you want to follow along this this
link here I'll paste it in the chat as
well
oops paste this link in the chat um it
does require a bit of setup you need to
have Docker on your computer um we're
going to be running mini Cube as a
kubernetes
cluster um which is a way to kind of run
a kubernetes cluster on your local
computer and the reason that we're doing
that is just to make it really really
easy to in a couple minutes get started
with with doing this now of course in in
practice you're going to want to do this
on a on a full scale kubernetes cluster
um that that has serious cloud resources
behind it or is running in your in your
data center with whatever kind of GPU
workers you have on it um but this is a
really quick way to kind of get your
hands on get the feel of what it's like
to work with these systems and then the
same code will be runnable and kind of
the same installation commands will be
runnable on your cluster um so this is
kind of a good way to practice is is why
I set it up this way here here okay so
I'm going to go to the repository and
just kind of show you that link that I
shared in the chat will take you to here
the torchx local part of this
repository and I'll just talk through
this read me because that's basically
all that I want to do in this section um
and
then uh yeah uh so I've kind of also
like prepared things um so we'll see it
looks like we're doing pretty good on
time actually so maybe I will do it from
scratch um but we'll see um so what
we're going to do is install mini Cube
and mini cube is this again is the
solution for essentially inside of
Docker so if you're on a Mac you can
install Docker desktop or if you're on a
Linux box and you just kind of have
Docker installed already um you can do
this if you're on Windows it's going to
be a little bit more challenging you
need to run the whole WSL system um but
you can pretty easily find like Docker
installation
um so kind of depending on your system
you can go to this
link and find out how to install Docker
um again if you don't want to follow
along here no worries you can follow
along after um and reach out to me on
the slack channel that that I'll share
in the slide deck um and I'd be happy to
help you anytime um if you want to just
kind of sit back and listen that's
totally
cool um okay so once we've installed
Docker then we can install this thing
called mini Cube um so there's a
separate link here in the repository to
install mini Cube um it should be it
should be very easy it's kind of one
command install for example if you're on
Mac I just did Brew install mini
Cube and then after that we're run a
mini Cube start which this will
essentially form a tiny kubernetes
cluster on your computer um so this is
pretty mind-blowing to me like I'm not
really a kubernetes expert um but I kind
of know enough to like get by and kind
of communicate with the platform
Engineers that set me up to do a lot of
this stuff stuff um and it's pretty
amazing that you can sort of replicate
the experience of the most powerful
compute clusters in the world on your
laptop kind of have the same developer
experience as somebody who's actually
interacting with those seriously
powerful clusters um another thing about
mini Cube that's interesting to think
about is if you have a bunch of on
premise gpus or maybe you have a dgx box
or um you bought something from Lambda
labs and it's sitting under your desk um
you can actually run mini Cube on those
boxes as well so you don't have to do
the full-on like Cloud deployment to get
the value out of kubernetes like all of
these same arguments will apply on local
hardware as well if you want to kind of
string together several gpus and have
the the skills to kind of connect them
into the the mini Cube cluster you can
just run it like this as well um which
is another really fast way to get
started um so let's actually just verify
I I've run this before kind of did the
the cooking show get get things prepared
a little bit so you could avoid seeing
me muck around in the command too much
um let's actually just verify that we're
kind of seeing everything here make this
a little
bigger so I'm in a vs code this is on my
local computer again um and what you see
here is that I'm running the mini Cube
um cluster and when I type Cube CTL get
nodes this is kind of like the
kubernetes command line tool the mini
Cube node shows up
um
and we can describe the node then so we
you can use this command and then we'll
use the name of the result here so for
everybody who's installed mini Cube you
should just see this unless you're also
already running other stuff um on a
kuber on kubernetes locally
um let me just go ahead and run
that so again when I do get nodes
there's going to be the mini Cube here
if you have a bunch of other nodes
running on your kubernetes
cluster um which in practice that is
what it will look like is if say if you
have
20 GPU nodes or something you'll see a
different node um when you do the qctl
get nodes command in that case um but
this will just print out a whole bunch
of metrics about what's happening on
this this node right now um so you get a
whole bunch of things like labels and
annotations this is all kind of like
fancy kubernetes engineer stuff like if
you're more in the data scientist AI
realm like you don't need to be focusing
on this it's kind of part of the idea
but it can be extremely useful to have
the basic experience of going through a
like this just to even know what
questions to ask the kubernetes admin
that enables you at your company things
like
this um okay let's keep
going um another thing this part's
optional but I I definitely recommend it
because it's a pretty cool way to kind
of get used to interacting with a
kubernetes cluster is that mini Cube
comes packaged with a dashboard so
that's what I have up here and what you
can see is kind of this really nice user
interface that shows you all the
different stuff that you can do in
kubernetes and then it's actually going
to be like it's going to be interactive
and it's kind of plugged into the mini
Cube cluster that's running on my
computer right now so you can see all
the different kubernetes objects that
you can create things like a Cron job
there's this concept of deployments
today we're going to be looking at pods
which is like the fundamental unit of
kubernetes if if you're not familiar
with it it's kind of like a an
abstraction that's like one level higher
than a Docker
container um
anyways yeah there's a bunch of good
stuff in here and this is where we're
going to kind of verify so instead of
just like seeing everything happen in
the command line we're going to want to
verify in in this interface what's
happening in the in the mini Cube
cluster just to kind of give a a little
bit more interactive
feel so once you have mini Cube
installed then we're going to install
this thing called Volcano um and
remember kind of the end goal here is I
should actually just start here the
reason that I want this volcano thing to
happen is because I want to use torch X
and torch X is this system to run your P
torch code in a distributed way so
earlier we saw the command for um like
how how to kind of do the MPI commands
it's very similar to this it's just a
way to submit a command to the the
compute cluster and then have that job
get scheduled on the compute
cluster and the way that torch X is
working with kubernetes so is the way
that torch X can communicate with this
mini Cube cluster or the cluster that's
going to be running on your cloud or
your on premise data center is through
um these kubernetes objects that are
enabled by the volcano
system um so that was kind of a lot of
jargon I I'll pause just for one sec to
see if there's any questions looks like
we're
good cool um maybe I'll actually just
take a one minute detour just to fully
flesh out kind of what volcano is and
why we're using it here um but it's a
project in the um Cloud native Computing
foundation and and there's a lot of
interesting companies that are backing
it uh mostly companies from from China
actually um people like um there's the
yeah here we go the supporters from like
Huawei 10cent BYU um so like some of the
serious players in the cloud engineering
space in China for sure um yeah
essentially what volcano is allowing us
to do is to schedule these batch jobs
these gang scheduled jobs um and to kind
of put them behind some queueing system
so it's like I can say I need four GPU
worker nodes each Having Eight gpus to
run this job but then maybe our company
only has eight such no compute nodes so
it's like there needs to be some way if
we have several researchers that are all
trying to compete to of get access to
those resources that work there's there
needs to be some way to kind of have a
queueing system so we sharing those
resources fairly and then also making
sure that say we have a production
workload um we don't want that to be
getting kind of intercepted or to be
getting preempted by me just running
some random experiments on any given
Tuesday um so okay that's a super high
level of what volcano is what we need to
do to actually make volcano accessible
inside of the mini Cube cluster or any
kubernetes cluster is to apply this
command um you can you can go ahead and
see like what the volcano crd is or like
what this installer is um by going to
the GitHub repository but what this will
do is it'll just create a bunch of
different op kubernetes objects
essentially that are customed to volcano
that enables all of this to work um so
I've already run that in my cluster um
so that I could just kind of keep keep
going here um without without too much
pause um but you you will need to do
that before any of the stuff below this
is going to work so like if you want to
run these torch X commands um you can do
this Docker one but you won't be able to
do the kubernetes ones until you run the
volcano
installation um and then finally there's
some hip dependency and this is the
torch X package itself so again I've
already run this it's inside of my
conduit environment for pi data um you
can install that on your computer like
any package you want to install from
pii
okay okay so let's actually run
something
um so what I want to do is first show
you that torch X Works independent of
kubernetes and then show you what it
looks like with
kubernetes so what we want to do is just
run this very simple script so you can
imagine this is like a training routine
for for pytorch code so this could have
your neural network training this could
have an evaluation step whatever job you
want to submit let's like think that
this hellow world. py file is any any
script like that that you want to submit
to the kubernetes cluster that has your
Pi torch code in
it so in this case what we're doing is
we're going to pass one argument to the
to the code code so maybe I'll just
change it just to demonstrate that we're
actually interacting with this code here
um so we're calling the hello world. py
scripts here and then we're going to
pass one argument so we should see hello
comma the result of that argument as the
result and the way that toor the torch X
part of this command is working is that
we're telling it to run this job and
then we get to pick a scheduler so this
is kind of the core functionality of
torch X is that what I'm telling you to
do here is in a local Docker um
container run this python script on top
of that container and then um like in
Docker language like add another layer
to run this script on top of the the con
the base container that you're running
from so I'm not going to go into more
details about where that container comes
from and things like this um very
interesting question like related to the
supply chain of this whole system um
let's just go ahead and run and see if
we get the the desired
result um which again what we should
expect is just kind of like some
printout
statement okay so I see the job failed
looks like maybe I'm in the wrong
directory uh yes so I was looking for
this hello world. piy file I see what
directory I'm in I'm still in the root
not this torch X local so I'm going to
CD into the torch X local directory and
now let's rerun the same
command okay now we see a different
result now this is the the result that
we wanted um essentially what happened
is based on the original image this is
the part that I was explaining about
like kind of adding a layer on top of
this default image that torch X decided
to pull so they've built and pushed a p
torch image into a container registry in
this case it looks like it's on Google
Cloud um and then on top of that we're
going to run this script with the
command that we passed with torch X
command um so we see hello Pi data and
then if we want to maybe change this we
can change it back to hello Pi data
Global
2023 and we can kind of get this
interactive workflow going um and you
might you might be wondering like why
why doesn't any of this matter right I
could just run the Python scripts like
normal I'm just do like hello world. py
Pi
data and then just like something
random um and like you could just run
this python script regular so why why
would you want to do this
we're actually like moving in the
direction of packaging this up so that
we can run it on many different nodes
and all those nodes are going to have
consistent compute environments and
we're going to be able to schedule that
job as a group um so again that's kind
of like the main thing that I want to
point out in this session is like we're
just trying to move one step at a time
in that direction and like get used to
like the core mechanics of what's going
on here before we kind of just hit run
on this massive compute job that's
that's happening in the
cloud Okay cool so that's step one now
we haven't touch the mini Cube yet so we
set up all the mini Cube cluster and
then we just ran inside of Docker which
um is not interacting with the mini Cube
yet now the next step of what we want to
do is we want to run the same exact
script that we just ran but inside of
that kubernetes cluster and the reason
for this is that this is the this is the
kind of connection to these massive
scale compute clusters like the
kubernetes cluster that like X is
running to train grock or that open AI
is running to train gpt3
um these massive scale compute clusters
are existing in the cloud most likely or
in somebody's data center on um and we
we want to kind of have the the muscle
memory of is this section is basically
trying to give you the muscle memory of
like what does it actually feel like to
interact with a cluster like that um on
a small scale but with the same exact
apis and code that you'd be using on the
large
scale so in order to do this we need to
start using the volcano system so the
reason that we inst installed this again
is it's going to install a bunch of like
kind of custom objects into your
kubernetes cluster is why is what
volcano is doing um and one of the main
ones is going to be the queuing system
so like we'll get into this a bit later
but like kubernetes doesn't exactly have
like batch job support baked into the
kind of the base kubernetes
implementation and that's one of the big
things that um volcano is adding to it
is this ability to submit B jobs and the
ability to submit them into a
queue so in order to get a q set up
we're going to apply this yo file called
q.o and if you don't know much about
kubernetes you don't know what yl file
is don't worry like it's not it's not
that crazy like it can be confusing but
there's nothing that special happening
here basically what we're saying in this
really simple yaml file is that we have
this kind of special API version that
comes from volcano and like we need to
have run that installation command to to
use this um and that enables us to use
this Q object that volcano provides and
then all we're doing is just naming the
queue um you can see that there's a
parameter here called weight that that
you can think about that as like that's
a way to kind of like judge the priority
of different jobs so say you had several
cues or you had several different types
of jobs that you wanted to submit into
this queue you can kind of apply
different weights to them is like what
that's the core thing that volcano is
providing um it's kind of this in
conjunction with the batch jobs okay so
we we got this Pi data torch X demo Q
let's go back and actually just run this
just to make sure that I have it okay so
I see it unchanged so I've already run
the um or applied this this emo file to
my kubernetes cluster and so we can see
that it says it's unchanged basically
like the queue already exists and the
file that I just tried to change it to
doesn't change anything so do
nothing um now we're going to run the
same exact thing the only command that's
changing is instead of the local Docker
we're going to run with
kubernetes so let's go ahead and submit
this and then we'll say
kubernetes um we'll get a similar build
um one thing that's different here in
this output is you'll notice that we're
actually pushing something to Docker so
in order to use kubernetes with torch X
um we actually had to create a docker
registry and a Docker registry is
basically a place where images get
stored um so this is because the
containers aren't going to only be
existing on my local computer anymore
the idea is that we're trying to like
move into this kubernetes land where the
containers are just getting moved around
between the container registry and the
computers where we actually want to run
this P torch code and torch X is helping
us orchestrate that but in order to do
it we need a place a kind of a central
place where it can go actually find the
images um so in this case it's in my
personal Docker Hub um but this could
also be a
registry um you you could also have a
registry this is going slow just get out
of it um you could also have a registry
on Amazon in ECR or Google has their own
registry Azure has their own registry
XYZ um for more like kind of Enterprise
security like you should consider doing
that um and also it's going to be much
much faster say if your kubernetes
cluster is on
Amazon it's going to be much much faster
if you're storing the compute images
that you need to move onto the computers
um it's going to be much faster if
they're in in the Amazon Cloud already
cool so coming back to what we were
doing here um what we can see is that it
launched the app and it kind of printed
the the Pod ID of the kubernetes Pod so
connecting back to what we were talking
about earlier with the mini Cube have
this wonderful dashboard and now we'll
see that the the same kubernetes pod ID
is now appearing here see that the job
is completed you can kind of Click into
it and see a whole bunch of useful
stuff um but what I want to do right now
is just to kind of demonstrate like what
the interaction Loop is like with the
kubernetes cluster um this is kind of a
very vanilla or like day Zero sort of
interaction with kubernetes we can use
the kubernetes command line tool to
fetch the logs of that container so just
like when we ran in the local Docker
container there's going to be logs that
are kind of printed out to the standard
out so it'll it'll look just like kind
of if we had run this in the docker
container but again like we're running
inside of an isolated kubernetes cluster
on my computer that could be running
anywhere in the cloud or anywhere in the
data center um and then we can just
access those logs seamlessly and kind of
get the the full observability back
there cool so I'm going to pop back to
the chat now that's kind of the end of
that section and then there's going to
be a more involved Computing section um
at the close close um it looks
like good
on okay yeah looks like there's nothing
new in the chat cool so I'm going to pop
back to the slides for a little bit um
just to kind of extend the story in a in
a bit of a different direction and kind
of move us back into the python
ecosystem a little bit more directly um
and then we're going to run a more
serious scale job in the cloud um to to
close out the
session cool
um so now again like you can see kind of
this little purple dude here like is
kind of symbolizing the like what we
just did like where where that person
that's kind of like typing away on her
keyboard and everything I was doing was
contained to my laptop now it's like
obviously I need to get powerful
computers I need to be able to run these
these jobs in an actual workflow system
to like create real software not just
something where I have to be sitting
there typing in my computer to make it
happen but something where maybe new
data comes into the system the job just
runs automatically or every week we just
kind of rerun the job just to keep
things fresh things like this um so I
want to like kind of zoom out and kind
of compare AI systems in general and
machine Learning Systems in general to
how traditional software works so
historically we kind of have this this
valuable system where like the goal of
the engineer is to kind of build
something that's going to run reliably
without a human in the loop so like you
don't want to kind of have to always be
responding to like a request in your
product or your application
with an engineer actually getting like
needing to be in that Loop you kind of
want the system itself to be able to
make the decision is kind of one of the
ways that you can think about building
valuable software in
general now with ML there's a whole
bunch of new stuff that gets introduced
into the system so the value producing
system still needs to be correct and it
still needs to run reliably without
human supervision but there's all this
extra complexity where now we have this
like this purple person like it's us
playing around with the High torch code
and like building new models um but even
more than this it's like the whole
system is starting from data in the real
world that's changing so unlike a kind
of rule-based software that says if this
then do that um we're producing correct
results is much more well- defined now
we have kind of these like slippery re
real world data distributions and then
those are getting pushed through machine
learning models that are also based on
probability and statistics um and things
that can often be kind of hard to
control the correctness of
um especially recently in this whole
like language modeling space um so all
this stuff is new and it introduces
extra complexity into the
system um and I guess to to kind of
connect to this graphic the idea is to
try and simplify a lot of that
complexity and to really zoom in on um
before we kind of mostly had like the
code is what we were focusing on in the
traditional software description and now
we sort of have this Triad of
interaction between data models and then
the code
so the data and the models like this is
a lot of what we've been talking about
so far is like how do you fit the models
and how do you fit the data onto the
right computers to actually get the
models to learn something so that
they're useful in your product or
application in a new way um the the
connection here is really compute
because in order to make the models
learn from data you need a lot of
compute power and a lot of memory on
those computers to make it
happen then so like connect this into a
system where you you can actually run it
on a schedule or you can run it based on
new events happening in a system or even
maybe you just need to run a couple
different versions of the model in
parallel with different hyperparameters
say um you need a system to orchestrate
this so we need a way to kind of connect
the different models that get built into
the code base that actually defines how
those models get
trained um and the key thing that like
we really focus on an outer bounds and
is one of the reasons why I like working
at the company is we focus very much on
like what is the experience of the
humans like whether it's this purple
person this like data scientist type or
the yellow engineer um it's built by
humans and it's built for humans at the
end of the day so focusing on like what
the experience is like to access compute
and to build systems that can
orchestrate these workflows it's really
important to kind of consider like what
is the experience like for these people
and how do we make it easier for them to
focus on the right layer of abstraction
that um helps them get their job done
helps them make value for their business
so on and so forth
um the systems are also built
iteratively so it's kind of like another
thing to really think about is like how
do we kind of orchestrate this whole
thing but then at the same time like
each of those runs of the orchestrated
system somehow needs to kind of be
versioned because the these scientist
types especially the new people that are
in the picture producing these valuable
software systems their main job is to be
iterating is to be considering what
experiments can we run how can we
consider like putting two models in
production and seeing which ones is
doing better in a more systematic way
things like this um in in that world
versioning becomes extremely important
where we need to be tracking all of our
experiments we need to be tracking all
of our results and then we need to be
able to access back to the workflows
that produced the models and connected
them to the data sources even the
environments that ran on the computers
like we were just seeing with Docker and
kubernetes kind of need to be able to
version that entire system end to end in
order to to have a reliable robust
valuable system
um so now connecting this back to like
the HPC part of this talk like there's a
whole bunch of stuff in the machine
learning stack that has nothing to do
with HPC is kind of the point of this
slide um the the team at outer bounds we
work on this open source rmer called
metaflow that kind of acts as like a
substrate across all these different
layers of the machine learning stack um
and the compute layer is a very
important one and it's becoming
increasingly important for building your
own AI systems if you want to say train
a large language model or train a
diffusion model like stable diffusion um
but it's still just one component and it
needs to depend on Enterprise Data
Systems whether that's data bricks
snowflake or an S3 storage solution um
and it needs to connect to all these
other different layers of the stack to
to Really Drive value Beyond kind of
being an experimental research
tool so I want to show you quickly how
metaflow actually does this so this link
is going to go back to the same
Repository but just to a different part
of
it um
and that's going to be in the torch run
cluster
so what exists here is essentially very
basic instructions um it's really high
level so if you need help please reach
out on slack because like I'm not
expecting people to be able to follow
along right now it requires that you
have a full deployment of metaflow um
which I can show you the documentation
is
here ahead and Link this um and then if
you're looking to get started with
metaflow we have a bunch of instructions
on how you can how you can do this like
how the engineering resources work which
this is kind of the ways that you can
deploy it on your Cloud you can also
deploy it on premise
um but the main idea here is that
metaflow is kind of acting as a layer
that connects your python code your
pytorch scripts very similar to how we
were seeing with torch X um and it does
this in a very general way that's not
unique to pytorch py learn any kind of
system that you might want to build or
any data engineering framework um but it
kind of connects your python codes in
your Jupiter notebook like layer of
thinking into these like production
systems so you can have one of these
like Yello Hat People one of these
platform Engineers say deploy Metal Flow
once and then you can have many
scientist types all be kind of
submitting their jobs to it running them
on a schedule running them when new data
comes into the system these kinds of
things so what we want to do is um run
let me actually just go to vs code it'll
be easier to see
everything um what we want to do is go
into this torch run cluster directory so
I'll go ahead and do
this and we're going to run a GPT model
so we're going to train this GPT model
um and this is coming exactly from um
Andre karpa's MPT Rico if you're not
familiar with that it's definitely worth
it's definitely worth checking out um
it's about a year old now but he wrote
this excellent repository that is one of
the simplest implementations maybe the
simplest implementation of what the GPT
models are like what these Transformer
models are um so this repository has a
bunch of like excellent P torch code
that's really easy to read um I mean you
can see as evidence by 2,000 people have
forked this repository um it's really
kind of like made the waves and machine
Learning Community but basically what
we're going to see here is how you can
run that training code um in a few lines
of of metaflow
code um well I should say the ptor code
is the exact same but we're kind of
connecting it into metaflow as a
workflow system so we're kind of
building on top of his research code and
then just plugging it into a machine
Learning orchestration System that's
going to help us run it and get access
to all those resources without having to
think of it kind of like calling back to
the idea of like we want to separate the
cons of like how do I get access to the
compute to the research cluster um and
then like like how do I like actually
write the research code we want to kind
of like separate those two things which
is what we're demonstrating
here so in order to run it um there's a
very simple command that you can do with
metaflow I'll actually just type it out
python
flow. it's package suffixes is we just
are telling metap that we want to
include a yaml file in the Run
um actually I'm going to need to go into
the main GPT repository we see here um
and then I'll copy paste this command
and run it and I'm going to explain
what's going on here because this is
going to take a while because what we're
actually doing in this case is we're
going to be submitting a job to run on
AWS batch and that's going to have eight
gpus on each node and we're going to run
two different nodes of that job so this
is kind of getting even further in the
Direction so like before we ran a local
computer now we're running in the cloud
on multiple nodes in the cloud um and
you can imagine kind of like stealing
this out and then um like one of the
main value propositions of metaflow is
that if you say want to switch from AWS
batch to kubernetes it's very very easy
um I'll show you in one second
here um before I before I talk too much
about like kind of how metaflow is
communicating with AWS batch I just want
to like connect fully to the the
research code
um so you'll see here we have this torch
run argument which this is very very
much like the command that we ran in the
terminal before to use torch X to run a
python script and then say pass some
parameters into it things like this um
so what we're doing in this current.
torch run command is we're passing an
entrypoint file this main.py
file and this just contains the
pre-existing research code from carpo's
repo essentially um so the idea is that
like I didn't need to modify any of the
research code I was just able to plug it
directly into a workflow orchestration
system that has the ability to access
like huge powerful computers in the
cloud and kind of on demand build me a
small but like very powerful HPC cluster
and you could totally scale this up um
and or or you could use it with on-
premise resources in a static compute
cluster um like again if you kind of own
your own gpus and want to connect such a
system to that um so what this research
code is doing is this main function is
just kind of setting up the distributed
data parallel so we kind of talked about
the distri the difference between data
parallel and model parallel earlier in
this case we're actually seeing an
implementation of data parallel in
pytorch code um we're loading up a bunch
of different config files one for the
model itself one for the optimizer one
for how we're going to load data onto
each computer um so remember in the data
parallel case like each computer is
going to get a different slice of the
data and pytorch has a bunch of really
nice features built into it to make that
a super easy operation for
you um and then the core thing that
we're doing here is just calling this
trainer. Trin which that's actually
what's going to kick off the process
where the model
learns um so if you're curious you can
go more into this trainer file this is
where the actual magic of that is
happening um so you can see like the
important part is going to be this train
function this is kind of the core Loop
that's running the different epochs of
the neural net training um that's not
really the main focus of this talk um so
I'm going to go back to the the workflow
file again this is the thing that calls
that main script um and the the reason
to kind of like separate the research
code from this workflow file is now the
the workflow itself becomes this like
nice little package of what is this 48
lines of code um where we can call that
that script and then we can have it run
in a bunch of different ways so right
here what we're saying is we're saying
like Okay we need to pass some
environment variables in I know that
we're going to be running on gpus so I
want to actually profile the utilization
of my gpus um all these little
decorators these little at symbol like
annotations on top of the function these
are kind of like metaflow Syntax for
adding different features that are
inside of metaflow um to run to run this
code um but like in this case we have
the GPU profile which this is saying
like I want to track how much memory um
how much um how much of the compute
basically am I using on that machine so
after I run this once maybe I'll have
okay I only use 60% of the resources
maybe I don't need such a big GPU
something like this um or or even more
you might see where where your code is
bottleneck and kind of see how to change
things um but then the two big
decorators that we're using here are
this at batch in at torch run so the at
torch run is what's enabling us to kind
of get this
ability to to specifically submit a
torch script and run it like we saw with
torchx earlier um and then the at batch
is what's connecting us to AWS Dash so
when you deploy metaflow there's a bunch
of templates where you can essentially
kind of print the whole metaflow stack
inside of AWS Google Cloud Microsoft
aure um and in this case we're using AWS
batch is the compute back end so AWS
batch is kind of a solution that's
that's built on AWS for exactly this
kind of thing um and they have this
notion of a multi-node job where you can
have many different computers kind of
spin up run a container just like we saw
with the kubernetes on the mini Cube
cluster and then have those containers
communicate each other um for something
like distributed data parallel or for
model parallelism
whatever um there's not too too much
else here so maybe maybe what I'll do is
actually just log into the AWS console
and I can show you what's going on a
little bit more
detail okay so here's kind of like the
base view of the AWS console if I click
into the batch part we can see a bunch
of different job cues so earlier we when
we were going through the volcano
example on the mini Cube cluster
remember we manually created a queue and
we needed to install volcano to do that
because that doesn't exist by default in
kubernetes um that does Exist by default
in AWS batch and it's part of the
benefit maybe of using a managed service
is that that that feature just exists
already for you in AWS batch um so if we
go back to kind of referring back to
this picture well right now we're kind
of in this middle bucket whereas before
when we were doing the mini Cube
business that was more in this top
bucket um so like maybe one benefit here
is like the queue is already created for
us essentially as a feature and I can
just go to job cues and kind of Click
buttons and make the happen this way um
now of course in practice you might not
want to do that you might want to do it
all programmatically um which which is
um something that the outer bounds team
can definitely help you out with um but
essentially you can see that we have all
these different cues and the job that
I've submitted is running in this queue
um so you can see we have a multi- node
job again remember we had two nodes so
metaflow is helping us specify in our
python code that I want two nodes to run
on AWS batch I want each of them to have
AG
gpus we can see that the job is has the
status of starting right now um so
whether you run on kubernetes AWS batch
it's very important to have some system
for monitoring the life cycle of these
jobs um especially ones where we're
requesting pretty massive amount of
resources here on each node so it makes
sense that it's taking a little while
for for AWS to provision those resources
for us um so like that that's basically
what we're seeing here is we're seeing
met flow kind of propagate these logs of
statuses
starting we can click into the node and
kind of see a bunch of different
information on AWS batch about what's
happening here um like in particular you
can see like a bunch of confusing stuff
here which is um okay I I don't want to
say it would be this bad but like the
experience of maybe using something like
AWS batch without a system like metaflow
or torch X is that you you kind of have
to like get into the level of like
actually submitting command commands
inside of a like figuring out what
command should run inside of the
container that AWS batch sees whereas
with metaflow remember we all we did was
we just ran this command in the terminal
so basically like regular python script
command plus a couple arguments and then
run and then metaflow kind of took care
of packaging up all that stuff for us um
and it it sort of took care of like
specifying all the different resources
we needed in the batch containers um as
well as preparing things like
environment Vari and doing a bunch of
other fancy stuff on top of
it so what we're seeing now is um that
metaflow is now kind of taking all of
the different things that are happening
um in the rest of the cloud system so
it's like kind of setting up an
environment meaning that in this case um
this could be like a conduit environment
or a set of packages from pip um but in
this case what we're doing is we
actually built a custom Docker image so
similar again similar to the the the
mini Cube case that we saw earlier
there's like somewhere existing there's
this Docker registry that I've created
and then there's a Docker image called
MPT that's tagged with the label three
um so we're kind of telling metalo here
like pull that into the AWS bat
container that we want to run here so
that's what it's doing when it says
setting up task environment
here um and then it's going to go ahead
and run run the code in this job which
again is just running this this training
Loop here
so we should see that start to happen in
a few minutes um maybe it can take like
between five and 10 minutes um to to run
jobs where we're requesting kind of
these big computers um so yeah that's
kind of like the the super high level go
ahead and check if there's any
questions looks
good um let's
see another thing that I can show you
while we're waiting here is that meta
also has a UI so like before we were
kind of monitoring on this mini Cube
user interface um metl also has a user
interface for monitoring jobs that we
submit um so you can see here like
myself and a bunch of teammates have
been submitting jobs to the same
deployment of metaflow and what I
earlier I was saying that the workflows
being versioned becomes extremely
important like whether you're doing HPC
work or whether you're doing kind of
just like regular um data processing or
more data engineering pipelines whatever
kind of AI ml system data system that
you're trying to build um you you kind
of want to version these workflows so we
named this one M GPT which is matching
the name of the the class that we
created here for our workflow
definition and if we click into it we
can start to see what's happening um so
you can see that there's two nodes
running again we're in two in
parallel kind of starting up we can see
the task logs getting
going um so we should expect to see the
training Loop starting
soon um but metaflow has a bunch of
different functionality built into this
UI to help you monitor jobs um kind of
help you do data visualization outputs
sort of build these dashboards that you
can then send to some end user or maybe
like a business executive that wants
kind of observability into all the
different workflows running in a
production system um or or a development
system where like something like HPC
might be more more common
um me
think see if there's any more slides to
go
[Music]
through um well that's going I kind of I
I kind of just want to zoom back out um
maybe do a quick summary for a couple
minutes and then um save time for any
questions at the end if we have a couple
more minutes um essentially what we've
talked about today is that the cloud is
is here and um everyone's kind of moving
to the cloud um this is in inclusive of
these like very demanding compute
intensive AI workflows um recent events
have made it even more kind of in demand
to do things with AI and we talked about
sort of the different ways that the
leaders in the AI Community are
demonstrating that there's a couple
different parameters that you want to be
able to to scale up um and we kind of
made the arguments earlier in the
presentation that compute is one of
those ones that you can invest in that
investing in it in the cloud is becoming
increasing the good
option um and then to do so we need we
need some systems for running these
batch jobs whether it's AWS batch like
we just saw whether it's on
kubernetes um with like kind of these
custom operators like volcano which is a
very active kind of Realm of R&D if
you're a kubernetes
expert um what whatever the case may be
on how you actually get the
infrastructure available to scientists
um the the compute Primitives are very
similar to kind of traditional HPC
workloads so there's a lot of things
that we can learn from systems like MPI
we might even want to be using
MPI um and we kind of like saw how that
connected to torch run and how like the
most common way to run these Pi torch
models right now um is typically using
the torch run or using MPI um and then
finally like we kind of saw how metaflow
can help you take these HPC Primitives
and make them more accessible to data
scientists make the Clusters easier to
manage for engineers um and kind of help
you just get going fast and then figure
out where the optimization targets are
if if optimizing the HPC cluster is
really within scope your
organization let's go ahead and see got
any results coming
in okay awesome so now we see our job is
actually starting to run so we're
logging kind of the loss curve of the
the um the neural network training so we
have a bunch of different gpus all
contributing to the same job um they're
kind of spitting out the logs here and
then if we go to the other task that's
running because remember we have two
nodes we'll see that they're all kind of
aware of what's happening in the rest of
the ecosystem um so there's they're
starting the GPU index in this case from
um 8 through 15 because this one's going
the first one's going from0 to seven um
so we kind of see that all 16 gpus are
contributing their resources to to the
same neural network training here um
which that's essentially the punch line
of the demo um not not too much
interesting in these logs beyond beyond
kind of seeing that so I'll pop back
over here and then just wrap up
quickly um yes if you're interested in
this stuff um and metaflow sounded like
an interesting tool for you to check out
uh we've been writing a bunch of blog
posts about this lately um here's two of
them um the one on the left is kind of
an introduction to how we view the
compute layer in that machine learning
stack diagram and then the one on the
right is showing you what we just saw is
how to use this at torch run decorator
but we've made some other ones as well
in our working with uh the Comm the
metlow community on building
more um so you can check out those two
posts if you're
interested uh there's a bunch of stuff
to learn about doing HBC in the cloud um
I really like the slurm the introduction
YouTube series I think is really good
and it's a really good framework even if
you have no intention of using slurm to
to learn from um there's um there's a
bunch of great resources coming out
these days around kubernetes eating high
performance Computing um it's kind of a
very desirable thing for a lot of folks
and there's a lot of great kubernetes
Engineers out there so that's that's a
really good set of resources to learn
from um Al also all the cloud providers
kind of have their own um incentives I
guess and their own um kind of product
lines built around doing doing
distributed training in different ways
um so like the there's kind of these
like HPC fundamentals style information
like the HPC Tech shorts from AWS or the
cloud HBC toolkit from Google um there's
also just like the basic kubernetes
cluster resources that are very helpful
if you if you want to use kubernetes to
do this kind of stuff um and then that
that kind of third bucket the highest
level maybe the fastest way to get
started kind of these these sag maker
like apis um is is very useful too if
you're if you're kind of trying to fast
trck how your organization can get going
so to take a look at
those um and to close out um definitely
check out Metal Flow check out Outer
bounds if you're interested in kind of a
managed version of Metal Flow or if you
just kind of want to get in touch with
the team that's doing a lot of the the
building of metaflow and the maintenance
of it um we also have two more talks um
so outerbound CEO vet tulos is going to
be giving a talk called compute anything
with metaflow so sort of a little bit
higher level than this this talk um but
he's going to be talking sort of about
um all the different ways that you can
use metaflow like far beyond HPC that's
just kind of a tiny slice of the
worldview he'll be presenting um and
then our head of developer relations
goana Anderson um he is giving both a
talk and a tutorial um his tutorial is
at one specific time today where he's
going to be going through some of the
fundamentals of using metaflow um so
maybe like a lot of the stuff that's
kind of prior to this more involved high
performance Computing way of of looking
at metaflow um we'll be kind of looking
at the more basic fundamentals like how
does this just help you build robust
software systems in
general um so definitely check out those
talks um I'm sure they both be really
interested
um and then finally we have a very
active slack community so if you want to
join um over 3,000 now data scientists
software Engineers um people thinking
about all the stuff that we're talking
about today um join our slack um and
feel free to reach out be happy to
connect with any of you thank you um
please if you have any questions um I'll
monitor the chat
now does metaflow work with Kos yes
absolutely metaflow works with Kos um so
there is a bunch of resources here at
outer bound.com
um that I can point you to in the how-to
guides I believe there's one for Kos yes
so right here I can paste the
solution this is like a kind of a higher
level like there's a lot of different
ways that you could integrate metaflow
with chos but I guess the real punchline
is that these workflows that you write
with metaflow they're all following the
same structure of subclassing this flow
spec object and then the functions of
that object are the steps in your
workflow um you can put any python code
in here is really my point so that this
is inclusive of of any Kos code any
numpy code P torch XYZ learn yeah